hello everyone so welcome welcome to my
talk and welcome to the conference
I helped set this up five years ago when
we started the first Pi Day to London
when we had two hundred people or so and
then over five years we've grown to five
hundred people and I'm really happy with
the growth of our ecosystem I'm not
really a unicorn data scientist I joked
at that - Cassandra Lane I didn't think
she'd actually say I do not
self-identify as a unicorn at all I'm
just a data scientist senior they
designed this so we're doing this for
quite a long time for just a data
scientist so I'll be talking today on
creating correct classifiers I had a bit
of a shock when I checked the schedule
last night or yesterday afternoon and I
saw that Gale vertical it's gone did he
come into the room alright so Gayle gave
a rather excellent tutorial on debugging
your classifiers and estimators last
night and I read the abstract that it's
not oh my god how much we overlapping
and it turns out not so much which is
handy how many people went to Gail's
tutorial yesterday
I've got overhaul for you right okay
well I'm glad I'm not overlapping quite
so much then for those of you that
didn't go to it the material for girls
talk will be online as a video and I
urge you to go and watch it will cover a
lot of very interesting points
definitely worth catching at that and I
think I've linked it in the appendix at
the end of my slide so you can get a
link from there when these go online so
Who am I I'm an engineering data
scientist so I do not have a PhD I do
not have the I do not have the typical
academic data scientist background I've
made everything up as I've gone along
for 15 years and it turns out with lots
of trial and error
lots of error and some things that work
and you keep keep hanging on to the
things that work in the end you get kind
of good at something and that's that
kind of handy so I've been doing that
for 15 years I was employed at the
beginning in some startups and then I
started consulting are for that and I've
been happily consulting ever since I get
to work on a wide variety of problems so
I'm slightly a jack-of-all-trades turns
out I am getting some deeper domain
knowledge in certain areas over the
years but I have a rich intellectual
life tackling different problems makes
me really happy
and it's one of the reasons why I
promote the growth of our PI data
ecosystem because more interesting
people come every month to the meetups
how many people come to the meter
at least one of our meetups alright so
not enough of you so more of you should
come to our meetups because let me go to
the pub afterwards and I get to have
beers with really interesting people and
I get to learn stuff and that makes me
happy and that's why I do all of this it
is ok alright there's we do have a
scaling issue I do encourage horizontal
scaling we can't do vertical scaling
anymore with the meetups 200 people
every month is the size of my first ever
conference and we run that for free now
with aho one of our sponsors outside
we can't keep scaling that up not for
free every month that's an unfair burden
on all of our volunteer organizers so we
encourage horizontal scaling with more
meetups but for those of you that can
make it along all just come to the pub
afterwards the pub you can just walk
into the pub afterwards come and join us
for drinks and so I work with a lot of
different companies over the years
various financial groups I'm working
with QBE insurance at the moment they're
one of our sponsors and one of my
colleagues will be talking after the
break Liam on some of the challenges in
the insurance industry so if you're at
all curious about problems where you
have really distorted long tail
distributions with lots of no events
huge numbers of no events and in small
numbers of really really long tail
events which is quite different to many
other industries I urge you to come and
attend Liam's talk all go and meet some
of the team out there and just talk
about it the stats are really
interesting obviously I'm a founder of
Pi Day to London I've got some of my co
organizers in here we're all volunteers
building up the meetup and the
conference over the years
I run the model inside that's my team
Salton Sea with a couple of other
colleagues and I blog on Ian Oslo calm
if you're interested in this kind of
stuff I've got loads of past talks up on
my blog and loads more material I've
also written a book high-performance
Python that's this one here I'll be
doing a book signing free books right
there's three of us doing book signings
Holden with spark Steve Holden with
Python reference and my high performance
we'll be doing it after this during the
lunch break there'll be a cue when the
books run out the books run out there
free first-come first-served one book
each signed by the author of course you
want to come and get one of these books
but there'll be a long queue so you
better get there quickly before I begin
my talk proper non focus backs all of
the PI data
conference and
supports all of the meetups around the
world we've got I think 97 meetups at
the moment I'm giving a keynote in a
couple of months time I want to get to a
hundred meetups why the engine anyone
wants to start a regional pied-a-terre
event around the world I want three more
in the next three months so I can claim
a hundred meetups in pi data and by the
time we speak of this keynote at Europe
- one of the key organizers behind num
focus is Lea Lea has been here every
year the reason you're here is because
of Lea's efforts she runs everything in
the background she's a hidden figure who
brings every one of the PI data
conferences together she broke her foot
recently and so she couldn't travel so
she's a bit poorly she's recovering
she'll be fine but she can't be here she
really misses the London community so
who in the room has got Twitter on their
device right now hands up I suspect more
review than that hands up come on
honestly hands up if you've got Twitter
on your device right now that's a bit
more like it right every one of you no
excuses every one of you please send out
a tweet to numb focus with a message
along the lines of Lea get-well-soon
from London or thanks for helping to
organise Pi Day to London or any other
kind of positive wish and I don't want
one or two I want every one of you who
has got Twitter on your phone because
you're here because Lea one of the
unspoken heroes helped to provide
everything that happens around here and
she's feeling a bit poorly she'll feel
so much better if she realizes that Pi
Day to London's community are thinking
about her so please send out a message
to at nom focus Lea get well soon all
thank her for bringing this all together
and that will make the world a little
little bit of a better place today and
that'll be love so goals today we're
gonna look at developing a baseline
model for your classification the same
same general approach applies to
regression I spent last year talking
about some regression problems and I've
got a bunch of notebooks dealing with
regression and diagnosing them diagnose
in those models so this year I'm gonna
talk a bit more about classification
Diagnostics so we get a baseline model
to make sure that we are progressing
from a baseline we're going to talk
about visualizing errors and diagnosing
why predictions are being made and why
problems are occurring we're going to
improve our ability to communicate about
to our colleagues especially non data
scientist colleagues um I've got to get
hub repo I've got a whole bunch of
github repos but the one that matters
here is data science delivered I've been
slowly collecting a pile of advice it's
kind of advice that I wrote to myself 10
years ago that I wish I'd heard 10 years
ago
so rather than this bumpy self-taught
lesson over 15 years I could have taken
a bit of a shortcut so I've got a bunch
of advice in that data science delivered
and a bunch of notebooks the notebook
that generates the examples here isn't
in there yet but it will be in a couple
of days time once I've tied it up I've
been hacking quite furiously at that but
you should check out that data science
delivered github repo it's just under my
name so it's Ian Oswald on github so I'm
gonna introduce a bunch of tools that
help us to prepare for machine learning
just a couple of tools first one pandas
profiling who's used pandas profiling
alright hardly any of you brilliant so
pandas profiling that little tiny
screenshot at the top pandas profiling
dot profile reports bracket DF you pass
in a data frame you get a lovely rich
visual output around your data frame so
it's a bit like calling dot info
and describe on your data frame but
rather than getting a data frame back
full of text would you have to try to
interpret and think through you get a
bunch of diagnostic information this is
one of two slides on it so in this case
it's the the Cagle titanic data set that
I'm using and how many people have used
the quarter page sir I'm guessing
majority of you right so it's how many
people survived or died on on the
Titanic ship
it's a classic machine learning data set
it's quite small 891 observations
they're not big data at all less than a
thousand lines 15 variables there's some
missing data takes up a couple of
kilobytes not very not super interesting
from a richness point of view but great
for diagnosing things you can get a
counter the variable types in there's a
total of there's some numeric types and
categorical some boolean is fine the
warnings I think are the interesting bit
so some of the columns have got missing
values and if you if you're working on a
new data set and I often pick up a new
data set
to go and investigate can we do
something with this I get a diagnostic
look there's a bunch of data missing 20%
of the values in the age column are
missing you've got to do something about
that okay fine I've got high cardinality
on some of my columns so some of the
text features they just they're all
unique so is very high commonality maybe
that's interesting maybe not maybe and
the reports of some of my columns having
lots of zeros maybe zeros is bad that's
missing data perhaps in this case fairs
and parents children siblings and
spouses parks and CSP that just means
their accounts of zeros and that's
totally legitimate but for some data
sets maybe this is flagging a problem
the last line I think is kind of
interesting they're the one that's
rejected so I've made an age imputed
column I've imputed the median I'll show
that in a moment and it is highly
correlated with the age column of course
it is if it turns out you've got
hundreds of columns in a data set and
you haven't yet done some kind of
correlation check to see what's in there
this tool will just tell you look some
of your columns are correlated maybe you
don't want to put those into your linear
model only first go at a problem or into
any model maybe you just want to pick a
subsets if your columns that aren't so
correlated so it's kind of handy to get
an overview of your data sets you can
drill into different columns in the data
so that's the age column at top
two-thirds is the display you get that
per column so you get some more
descriptive data
quanto statistics descriptive statistics
there are four tabs worth of things
example data top counts bottom counts
for every feature that you've got and
you get a little distribution being
drawn out so you just get a visual check
as to what's in there so if you were to
throw this up on an overhead and then
show your colleagues look this new
dataset here's a couple of key columns
that I've pulled out for a sample of the
data and this is what it looked like
though to meet your understanding of the
the business that's behind this chunk of
data that you've given me as a data
scientist they go yeah that looks right
that looks right that one's got so much
missing data why is that it's an easy
communication aid and even covers things
like categorical data that embark'd
column has got three single characters
at the embarkation points and you get a
little bar chart counting and so it
handles really all the major data type
for just very nice it also does some
more correlation coefficient stuff so
we've looked at our initial data we're
happy with what we see we want to start
building a machine learning
model and the number of times and I have
done this as well a number of times
think I got this date of it's brilliant
I'm gonna build myself a random forest
then maybe actually boost maybe I want
to paralyze it maybe I can draw since
that but I really care about that I want
to do the fun stuff and you dive in and
you build a model and you get a result
you really I've got a result this must
be quite this must be a great result and
you forget to check what the underlying
behavior at the data set is because
maybe you've learned nothing at all
maybe you've got a really complicated
model that predicts the mean or just the
average guess I've done that I've seen
plenty of people do it and every now and
again well so yeah as a senior I do have
to step in and say right hang on let's
stop let's go back let's just take an
average is to see what the baseline is
because if we're not improving beyond
the average we don't need a complicated
model to make the average or you can
just take the average and simplicity
always beats complexity so certainly
from a diagnostic point of view so
scikit-learn has a dummy classifier who
has used the dummy classifier and the
dummy regressor not enough of you so an
okay like maybe you've taken the mean
and you haven't yet had to use the dummy
you know who knows but you should be
using this as your first step I tend to
go into any data set and try at least
some kind of baseline result so you can
import the dummy classifier
there are various strategies that you
can use in Gales talk yesterday Gail
mentioned using the default which is a
stratified sample of the data set I tend
to use most frequent for me if I'm
communicating with a colleague that I've
got a data set I know nothing about the
features but I've got this sir this
column that I'm trying to predict to you
that a classification column or a
regression column and sorry in a
classification case I can say that my
best guess as to the answer is the most
frequent answer it was the dumbest thing
that I could do so I tend to go with the
most frequent and then I want to see if
a model is outperforming that this
dumbest possible guess so
I take the dummy classify it works just
like any of you other classifiers I make
a train test split fit it fitting it
take sex train but it doesn't use X it's
only going to look at the distribution
of the the target column Y train and
then you score if you're part of the
next test it doesn't use that but it
fits the the format the interface of a
classifier and it only used is y test
and you get a score out so this is
telling me on that train set the most
frequent
answer is that survived survived to a
force most people died I know that was
the case with Titanic and if it predicts
that you died then it gets it right most
of the time 63% of the time in this case
here's a question for you with the
strategy of most frequent and you give
it another train test set it will be the
case that everyone the majority people
have died okay that's that's gonna be
the case every time you run this will I
get the same score out somebody give me
an answer if I run this again run train
test split fit score will I get the same
score the answer is the same the
majority people died so you predict died
will I get the same score how many
people say yes no one going with the
risky option and he was saying no I
guess it's everyone all right you're
right so because you're taking a
different train test bullet you get a
different distribution of ones and zeros
in your test set so when you score you
get a different answer slightly
different answer how different
I hear you thinking well if you do a
hundred folds you get the mean so great
we get 0.62 as the mean but look at that
distribution point five five two point
six seven five that's quite a wide
distribution just guessing is a majority
case but with different test folds you
end up with a wide variation in our
predictive ability and this ties into a
point that Gail was making yesterday if
you start building super super super
optimized classifiers or regressors
whatever some kind of super optimized
estimator and you're not taking into
account the underlying variants in your
data sets you can be super optimizing
away with your parameters and your
features but actually you're not
predicting any better your numbers are
getting better but if you're operating
in that noise bound then that's there's
quite a wide noise bound right if I run
my dummy classifier twice I could just
say one of them naturally looks better
than the other because it gets a better
score but that's rubbish let's represent
reality at all just variance in the
generation of these test folds and if we
draw it we get an idea of all that
variance looks like it's really simple
and to communicate this to your
colleagues so I encourage everyone to
start with something like this another
thing that happens certainly in the this
Titanic angle dataset is you impute you
mister
data because psychic learns classifiers
don't like missing data actually boost
will handle missing data so I could
learn random forest classifier won't so
we need to me to address that missing
data somehow so typical answer is
computer and impute it using the median
is a commonly used approach and then
nobody draws the resulting distribution
and doesn't have an idea in mind as to
how distorted things can look so on the
Left we're not showing 177 missing data
and man rows we're just drawing all the
true ages and we get a nice distribution
there are many kids and then there are
many kind of 18 is year-olds and then it
drops off towards older age people and
then if we impute the majority of the
data set is age 28 apparently and that's
a lie right we've just made this up
people ask me my position on imputation
I said well imputation is a synonym for
lie in my opinion and it's okay if we're
lying we know why we're lying about the
data but we're making stuff up we're
creating a fiction and we're hoping it
represents represents reality maybe it
doesn't and when you draw that and you
think why hang on a minute is it the
case that really everyone truly looks
like a 20 year old well no they don't
and if you go back to the raw underlying
data it turns out they really really
don't
it might work in a classification
context but you want to know what kind
of distortions you're introducing into
your data and if you're missing the
majority of data in a column and you
start imputed and not drawing the result
and then you were to draw the result and
show it to a colleague they might well
laugh and say but that that data you're
using doesn't represent the reality over
here at all that's why are you doing
that so if you draw things you get so
you get ahead of those kind of questions
very important so we've made a dummy
classifier we've prepared our data we've
drawn it we're happy we're not making
things up so let's go and build a better
some kind of better estimate so we could
get super excited we could go for XD
boost or like GBM or maybe a deep neural
network or something crazy but we don't
need to the first thing I always suggest
you do is step back and use something
very reliable that handles
nonlinearities and interactions in the
data so random forest psychic learns
built-in random forests incredibly well
debugged it just works we won't give you
the best answer on the planet but it's
gonna give you an answer that won't get
you fired which is very important it is
not gonna get it wrong right
it's gonna be better than the mean
answer with better be otherwise you've
got nothing going on in your feature set
and it should be better than you mean
answer it so your you've got this
baseline your dummy classifier then
you've got a new baseline this random
for us this is untuned so 10 estimators
are limited depths no hyper cram for
tuning just the basics I get a much
better answer and if I look at that
distribution so my mean has gone up from
point six to two point eight three and
my minimum value point seven six is much
bigger than the previous minimum value
so things have improved William so I
could be pretty happy that things have
become better and if we draw the two of
them together this is another really
easy way to communicate to colleagues
that have made an improvement I draw the
random forest that distributions up up
and better and the dummy classifier is
down and worse it's a brilliant
I can literally communicate quite
happily the even within the bounds of
the the noise in my train test
variations running it many times the
worst random forest result is still
better than the best dummy classifier
result brilliant right this is this is
no nonsense with is better now what I
haven't done is taken say two different
tuned random forests where one has got a
slightly better mean than the other and
then overlaid their distributions and
you can bet your bottom dollar the
distributions are basically gonna
overlap I mean maybe one looks kind of
convincingly by I to be a bit better but
often the mean might be slightly better
but that distribution that variance will
be wider these things all overlap but
it's not convincing the ones actually
better than the other and then back to
gales talk yesterday looking at the the
variance you get naturally in your data
sets if you haven't seen his talk I
strongly encourage you to watch it you
begin to sit back and think well yeah do
I really trust these slightly better
mean results am i increasingly
complicated --xg boost ensemble models
it's do I really you know am I getting
genuine benefit or am I just overfitting
my data set and not representing reality
at all because when you will you'd hit
reality there's all the whole bunch of
other variants that comes into play so
we want a simple reliable robust method
that will work over time and can be
diagnosed and that someone else can pick
up otherwise you're the one unicorn
corporate health unicorn you're that one
unicorn who understands your super
ensemble model and if you leave or get
hit by a bus no one else understands it
and the business has got a massive great
business risk and we don't want that we
want companies to be comfortable with
using machine learning so
want robust simple tools that just work
day in day out who's used the
yellow-brick library almost nobody not
enough people right and I can say this
because they very I kept filing bug so
they kindly made me a call and committer
on the project so and encourage you to
come and come and join use it find more
bugs help me figure out how to fix some
of these books and so the yellow-brick
project is a wrapper that takes
scikit-learn at estimators and tells you
things about them visually there's a
bunch of visual Diagnostics you can get
from the scikit-learn documentation most
of it is not about building graphic and
outputs though it's about getting the
correct answer and the scikit-learn
Doc's so yellow-brick tries to wrap up
ways of visualizing all of this they've
got some really simple things like the
confusion matrix on a two class problem
they just get this result it's not super
interesting right but if you've got the
digits data set when you've got ten
classes then you have a 10 by 10 matrix
and it colors it in nice ways and it's a
bunch of rapper code that you would
otherwise have to write yourself or
maybe you get it wrong it comes for free
in this library and for regression you
get regression prediction errors should
get nice and residual plots and there's
a couple of ways of diagnosing things
there they've wrapped up lasso and a few
other things to give some diagnostics
and there's more coming that's quite an
active team behind this so if you
haven't used yellow brick yet there's
one thing you want to get out today's
talk try yellow brick they just have a
look at the website and if they don't
have the visualizations that you think
would make your life easier
for a bug we call and say hey I'd like
to see something like this give them
some suggestions so other team members
can do something with it and if you see
something that useful give it a go
because visual Diagnostics stick in your
brain we're highly evolved visual
creatures and you can communicate these
very easily to a colleague so we see
here true class top left corner 127 so 2
class is 0 did people live or die well
they died and how many correct
predictions for died were 127 so a
majority was over most people died and
we got it right bottom right corner and
who survived this is in the test set a
subsample well of the true
who did survive then we predicted 61 of
them so that's pretty good but of the
people who died and we predicted a worm
do they survive that's 12 so it's a
little bit wrong and then of people who
did survive and we predicted they died
23 so that's a bit wrong too
this gives us some clues as to what's
going on in our data but it doesn't get
us further down and we'll go a bit
further into the weeds in just a moment
so one thing I've been playing with
recently I don't know if this has value
I think it has value maybe someone else
has done this and you can tell me this
has value
I've taken the confusion matrix and then
rather than looking at the raw count of
things in each of those four quadrants
I've taken the underlying probabilities
and histogram them so if you're in the
bottom right corner it's because your
predictive probability was greater than
50% and then it can be between 50% and
100% so between 0.5 and 1.0 and I've got
a histogram just you can count how how
confident the model is in these
predictions so for the predictions that
end up near 1.0 that's the model saying
oh it's like 100 percent likelihood
these people survived and for the true
negatives if all of the predictions
there are towards 0 percent the models
really confident these people didn't
just think they died it's pretty
convinced that they died that's great
if I were to look at this and see that
those histograms were moving towards the
50% rather than the 0 and 100% I might
think well my confusion matrix numbers
wouldn't change I still got the same
counts but the model is much less
certain if you have 45% and 55% for the
majority cases that feel kind of bad and
if we could say the false positives
you've got a small count of cases where
the predictions are just over 50% just
over 50% if we could do something to
improve that maybe we could drag it
under 50% and then it pops into the true
negative class and that'll be correct
rather than incorrect so we get an idea
as to where the model is going wrong I
may be what might want to focus our
efforts I haven't used this in anger I
actually do I've been thinking of me
doing this for a while when I developed
it for this talk so this could be guff
right we might decide this is actually
not informative but I think it is
informative I'm curious for some
feedback from you afterwards and I might
actually commit that into the the yellow
brick project so that it can be shared
around one problem we have in machine
learning is choosing which features we
want in our model laugh
feature selection process who's used the
Eli five project again not enough of you
right so Eli five who knows the Eli five
meme from reddit alright so you know
that right Eli five explain it like I'm
fired explained quantum computation as
if I'm a five-year-old take out the big
words
give me the nice big easy explanation I
can understand with colors and big
symbols or I make it make it super
simple Eli five is a Python library that
explains it like I'm five for machine
learning for scikit-learn so if your
thing fits inside KITT learn like
actually boost the like GBM fit into
starkly learn then Eli five can try to
explain those predictions for you that's
one of the things that does another
thing it does is offer this permutation
importance feature so at the top I'm not
using Eli five I'm using psychic learns
random forest feature importances and as
gala guy mentioned yesterday these are
calculated in a model of specific way
and between the models they're
calculated in different ways so if
you're comparing feature important
system a random forest vertices the
feature importance is that come out of
your coefficients for a linear model
versus actually boosts feature
importance is that it reports they're
calculated in different ways so maybe
they're not comparable permutation
importance that's a pretty nifty idea I
train my model I've done I'm done with
my train set put it to one side I've got
my test set if I run my model over the
test set I get some kind of accuracy
score coming out or some kind of score
coming at the end if by then randomize
one column of my test data at a time I
randomize it I put it so just I take the
same values and permute them up and down
randomly so it's the same distribution
but there's randomized in order
everything else in the test set is the
same I put it through my classifier I
get the same score out my score didn't
get any worse and columns completely
uninformative right there the classifier
is not used in that column if I permute
the second column and my score gets
massively worse there's a huge Delta in
those scores that means that second
column is incredibly important to that
model and you run through each column
one at a time and you find out which
columns if you permute them make the
worst change to the model and it turns
out if he permute is female that one
just really really messes up the
probably breaks everything so you that's
an incredibly important column and if
you did this for different model
you get a model agnostic way of
measuring single value feature
importance now it's single value it
won't take account of correlations in
data or anything I was only doing one
variable at a time but I think this is a
terrific better but it gives a different
insight as to which things are working
well or not in models so I encourage you
to have a look at this oh we can pull
out worst errors by rows this is
something I've been doing for a bunch of
years it's the easiest way to find out
that I've messed up my data preparation
all my data preparation has been lying
to me because the underlying data is
broken
so you get you get your true T values
you get your predicted values your
calculated l term you sought biggest
deltas first their biggest errors first
and then you pull up the underlying
passengers in this case their passenger
passenger ID 571 we predicted 0.07 week
so predicted that they died actually
they survived the error is 92% so if we
go back into the wall day to look at
passenger ID five seven one we might
find something interesting so if we then
sort our data and then we use the
fantasy pandas coloring and it you-purdy
notebook we can look at so the top row
is passenger five seven one second class
okay is female is four so it's a man
interestingly all those mispredictions
are men now men are the majority and the
data set so that might just be an
artifact but maybe there's something
interesting going on there and siblings
spouse parents and children totals are
very low so maybe that's interesting we
don't know low fares age imputed there's
quite a variety of Ages there well here
maybe maybe I need to dig into this some
more here because the data is probably
straight coming out of it a Kangol
competition maybe the data is not at
fault maybe the models at fault to look
at in a moment with a bunch of my other
real-world problems this is where
glaringly bad data prep comes out and
I've got the zeros rather than ten
billions and other things and so this is
brilliant that's forgetting a first idea
as to what the biggest errors are I can
go and fix those before I present to
anybody else to make an idiot of myself
one thing maybe we want to do they split
out our errors by some kind of
significant feature so p class and came
out as a significant feature so if we
split out our predictions for first
class that's I've got my predictions
then I filter just for the first class
people in that prediction set and then I
run a classification reports then I can
get some metrics out
precision and recall and I get some
averages point eight for 0.75 the first
class was predicted reasonably well if I
split out by second class my F of G is
point nine six point nine six so for
some reason second class is being
predicted better than first class that
might be an artifact of the data may be
the model can't do anything about it
maybe there's a data problem with the
first class recording maybe it was miss
recorded maybe the second class is
better recorded who knows and the number
of examples is similar in both so you
know I diagnose that here's another
thing that I made up for this talk I
think this is interesting this is
genuinely interesting so one problem
that I have one explaining things is I
get a row that's inherent I think okay
right this is an error what does it mean
to be in error and what do I need to do
to fix this one thing I want to see is
other rows that are like my row which I
get the row that's in there and I want
to find things that look like this row
and I could go and set up some kind of
tests in queries in pandas try to filter
out a bunch of similar rows by things
that I think are important to get a
bunch of rows that look similar by by
decisions that I've made but what if I
throw all of the test data into TCE so
it's an unsupervised dimensionality
reduction process check it entities need
visualize it in 2d then any data point
in feature space that's like another
point get to group together and then
points that are very dissimilar get
grouped along way away from each other
this is a first step in two steps
so all those points that are clustered
together they've got similar features
the target isn't included just the
features and it's the subset of features
that I think are predictive so I grouped
these results together and then I've
drawn circles for survived and crosses
for die that's the truth value now we
want to see which of the features that
group things together feel like they are
perhaps not giving us enough truth and
then do something with it so if we take
the same result and we color it by the
error so dark like black is low error so
these predictions are correct and yellow
whites that's really incorrect that's
like 90% wrong so if we look for some of
these regions I've got that point noted
out oddly similar cluster there's a
bunch of circles there they're all
darkly color
there's a couple of crosses in there
there darkly colored and there's a
couple of things that are not
mispredicted their errors is red so it's
not over the 50% bounder it's not gone
the wrong way but there is some error
there but it's kind of interesting this
is a whole big bunch of individuals who
are who are grouped together in this
dimensionality reduction technique and
there's this other region I've called it
conflicted where I've got bright yellow
circles so there's a bunch of people who
should have survived who are predicted
to die and so it's really wrong and why
is that but some of the predictions in
that space look good so what if what if
we group by X & Y and then dig into a
bit further so if we take the oddly
similar of region first of all and then
draw out the underlying features we see
that almost all the individuals are
third class okay fine and is female is
false for almost all of them so most of
them are men low counts of fair and
family size but look at that age imputed
what's special about 28 well well done
for using my terminology Jonathan yes so
we've made that number up now that might
be important it might not be important I
don't know but it kind of feels
suspicious to me and at this point I
mean I didn't know hunting for a region
to tell a story I just group to region
that looked interesting I mean it's kind
of interesting actually that's hey maybe
this crazy idea I had it has some value
and so I then went back to the the
Wikipedia page on who lived and died and
what was there there all their details
and I looked at the these individuals
and sure enough all those ages are very
different to 28 so this making up data I
mean I don't know if it hurt the
classification most of these
classifications are correct so maybe it
didn't hurt in this case but what about
the conflicted region so there if we
look at okay they're mainly first class
for the people that have got wrong but
of those first class people the agent
puted is typically 28 again so we've got
a bunch of made up data in a region
where it's getting lots of errors it's
miss predicting either way and I think
that's interesting in this data set
again it kind of views high variance as
to whether you lived or survived and
survives or died whether you've got near
a lifeboat or not so maybe we can't
diagnose this any further without better
information about where passengers were
and where the boats were and that kind
of thing but if I see that kind of thing
in my real world machine learning
challenges
and I see areas of high conflict and
it's where I started making up data or
I've got missing data I'm gonna get
pretty damn suspicious pretty quickly
that may be my underlying data is wrong
and it's not the machine learning
technique but the underlying
representation of reality that's at
fault
at which point and it's going to fix
that there's no point fixing the machine
learning I've got to go and fix the
underlying data so I think that's an
interesting diagnosis and then I'm going
to wrap up in a couple of slides so I
mentioned Eli five earlier one thing we
can do with Eli five is explain and
underlying prediction and this is really
quite handy for communicating results to
non domain specialists so in my case
working in insurance at the Roman I sit
with underwriters and actuaries and
Telep this is why the model is making
this prediction they don't know anything
about data science they use Excel
typically so there's quite a gulf in
terms of modeling understanding but
they've got all the business domain
knowledge that I don't have because I'm
not an underwriter or an actuary so I
can explain these kind of results in an
insurance context and they go yeah that
makes sense that makes sense that's why
I already do that and I go how that's
kind of interesting so I don't know
either I better go and dig into this I
bet the data is wrong and sure enough
the data is gonna be wrong in that case
so we get some shared understanding so
here the left hand example we look one
passenger two three one they survived
why did they survive why is the
probability of survival point nine nine
seven well according to this diagnostic
method and it's not like the only
diagnostic method but this is a pretty
good diagnostic method I think if you
pull out the underlying probability
contributions for each of the major
features in this complex set of
multi-layer trees that go into a random
forest and it works and actually boost
in the rest if you pull out the
underlying contributions that are
summarized by this process it is what
the the likelihood of survival is thirty
eight percent so it's less than fifty
percent but because is female is true -
this person is a woman we increase that
survival likelihood by thirty percent
according to the models interpretation
of the data their first class at another
thirteen percent on top and they paid
quite a high fare 83 pounds was quite
high so we had another 11 percent on top
and this adds up to our ninety-nine
ninety-nine point seven percent
likelihood of survival so that's
interesting look at someone who died
well 61 percent likelihood of death so
that's the easy guess and that increases
because they had a larger family and it
increases because they're in third
third class and it increases because
they paid a fair that relative to the
family size is quite small seeing a
third class in steerage but
interestingly this person is also a
woman so that decreases the likelihood
of death by 25% but still the sum total
of that is $19,800 it's a binary column
so at 0 or 1 so we're in the majority ok
fair enough
looking at sibling spouse parents and
children most people have zero some have
one some have two very few have five so
that's kind of interesting maybe there's
something interesting about having such
a large family
maybe that applies to other examples
where you have a large family they're in
third class and their age imputed you
can see okay the red bar is telling us
we're their ages and the age here is
what 16 but you can see that spike call
that 28-year old age and pewter coming
up
alright I'm being told game over so I'm
not going to talk about this except that
I'm going to talk about it in Amsterdam
and I reckon you should diagnose all of
your machine learning just like you
debug your code I've been pushing that
message for a couple of years I think
it's what you have to do I'm interested
in running some training around this
kind of things I'm kind of interactive
exploration I'm interested to know if
any of you want that kind of thing come
and talk to me give me some feedback
there'll be a write-up on in Ostrava
calm my blog I'm happy to answer
questions I have a request one thing I
hadn't been doing for years is asking
for anything in return I put a bunch of
time in all of our volunteer speakers
put a bunch of time in I mean ever ask
for anything I've started asking for
postcards as a result I've been
receiving postcards I've got a section
of all where I have postcards coming up
telling me that someone liked my talk it
makes me happy so please make me happier
send me a postcard send me an email I'll
send you my address send me a postcard
from anywhere in the world okay where
nor where from
just send me a postcard it'll make me
happy and yeah go and check out that
nope
and and there's an appendix slide which
when it goes online I have some more
links in and that will give you some
more background reading thank you very
much
so we have seven minutes until lunch so
do we have any questions no questions
everyone's hungry that's totally
acceptable em then you got a question
she keeps a contrite
I'm not asking is there a better way of
doing imputation so making up these
numbers no but there's ways you can work
around it because if you're missing the
data in your test set you've got to do
something about it so one way to do it
is to build a classifier with age
present and build a classifier without
age present and then when you've got
test later with age you can use one
classifier and then when you've missing
it you can use the other one or maybe
you can build up an estimator which
predicts one or the other and tries to
fill it in have you got a Oh God please
Robin was talking about is thought but
by what's known as multiple imputation
the IDS - the problem with imputation is
if you want to do post hoc analysis
after you impute and you impute by some
fixed constant you forget the variance
so there's a whole literature multiple
imputation and there are better ways of
there are many ways of doing it I was
thinking the simplest way of doing it
would be to sample in in the in the
distribution of the varville that you're
imputing and then you know random force
or an assemble model so you would simple
in this and then you would average and
of course let's implement this in
scikit-learn multiple imputation we want
to add things to psych you learn another
question another question so yeah what
happens when you can't fill your columns
on the screen and and genuinely a tough
problem and if you've got lots of
columns but only a couple of informative
that you can pull out just the columns
that are interesting because when I'm
communicating to a colleague I don't
care about all the minor effects most of
the time I just care about the major
effect so I try to explain just a subset
of the columns and when I've got
millions of rows and I want the diagnose
maybe I take a sub sample of thousands
and when you've got really weak features
so you need hundreds of thousands of
features with tiny contributions each I
don't have a straight answer for that
they're at it and there is an easy way
to explain that at the moment except for
probably lots of paperwork and figuring
out figuring a story that you can tell
that ties it all together I don't know
if there's I mean Gail might have a
different answer given his experience
with brain imaging and there's there's a
lot of data going into that any thoughts
or
I mean it's really tool specifics and
these tools will work well I mean
feature importance is computing the
gradient that local sample will work
well and then you know it varies but
some some things in theory should work
well then you've got implementation
problems these things are very scalable
I mean different the point they you have
a calculating feature importance out of
that isn't difficult I mean if you've
got hundreds of thousands of columns and
they've all got a similar tiny feature
importance then finding the truly useful
individual columns that you can tell a
story around that's hard and I don't
have a straight answer for that feature
is it's usually sensor data like brain
imaging or something like this and then
you know go back to the sensor data go
back so it's an image represented as an
image final question or should we break
for lunch I say we should break for
lunch let's break for lunch thank you
very much everyone
[Applause]